introducing speed cam there it is above
the first base dugout the mlb debut of
an enhanced view of the speed of the
game how cool is that canning our view
from speed cam a 488 era on the year
it's his seventh start of the season and
we've seen some ups and downs from him
so far as lewis dives back they got him
this time
kyle lewis caught napping at first base
nice move by griffin
dunn the 24 year old rookie on the mound
making his fifth start of the year 10th
career start for the right-hander
thompson baseball and rbis six of them
yesterday
that's loud contact to center field
lewis to the track he's got room and
makes the catch you know it's funny
usually body language you can tell
whether guy thinks he's got a ball or
not
he travels fully because he has the same
reaction every time two outs two on
brian
goodwin lifted to left
and comes marmalados
and uses the glove for some shade
pulls it to first for pujols covering
his canning
and marmalajos is out number two what's
the hardest part of that play catching
it or the throat that's not an easy
throw i would say the throw yeah exactly
it's a hard play it's an in-between hop
there's a clock he's got he knows the
runner look at that contact rate for
fletcher since his rookie season in
2018. i enjoy watching this good play
thrives with two strikes and he's going
to hustle the first and dunn will beat
him to the back and he fell down too
make sure he's okay
step afterwards yeah that left ankle
just put him off balance that lunge at
the base trying to beat it put his next
step off balance luis rendito replacing
david fletcher today and he's out of the
game
and he connects to right
to outpace it for ohtani that's what
kills you know he's obviously having
trouble catching up with the fastball
things
dug out
everything does sound really good off
the bat that's adele in foul ground and
he's got it ten outs recorded by justin
dunn five of them fly ball out so far
here comes pujols with two outs in the
fourth
albert one away from fifth all time on
the home run list and that's on the
ground
a little lollipop hop off the mound but
handled
marmalejos drops one into center
and he's got his first hit of the day
pitcher gives up his first hit usually
there's a little crunch time there it's
gonna be interesting see how he reacts
now because he's felt pretty invincible
and canning has made it through the
fifth inning just one time this year he
averages four and two-thirds per start
that's right back to canning look what i
found he got through the fifth the hard
one he did justin dunn going up against
this angels first four batters faced a
couple walks he's retired 13 of 14 since
then and he does it all too well he lets
the ball travel you know he trusts his
mechanics
you don't see him try to get too quick
his approach to hitting kind of fits his
personality
and doane chases
and they got him
big punch out for dunn
matches his career high six on the day
these are back-to-back impressive
performances from justin dunn
and goodwin skies it
cracks the bat on his way to first
oh look at that long ride to find the
baseball for hagerty basketball champion
was mostly what he was going with in his
last start those seem to be the two
pitches that he has the best feel for in
the past couple outings that's kyle
lewis driving it a long way and it's
gone
kyle lewis muscles up for the eighth
time this year the rookie sensation
breaks the ice
seriously you watch him and you wonder
why he wasn't even a top five pick
[Applause]
simmons gets it past the right side
and pujols is gonna truck home and it
was bobbled out there and right
alfred comes in to score
and now caught in between first and
second and simmons they have him but
he brings in the tying run
rbi knock
albert come on down shed long entering
the game first half out of the day
yep there he goes
and he's out
he pushed him out
he's already maybe pushed him off
runner in scoring position now for the
angels
2-2 to simmons
got him
here's tim lopes
that's cracked to left and a base hit
here comes lewis trucking home and he is
in there
the mariners grab the lead 2-1 on a tim
lopes rbi single ramirez is going to try
to get the job done and preserve this
one-run advantage brendon's not a guy
that jumps at you though you know he's
going to let the ball travel he's going
to see it as long as you can see it
it's popped up
[Applause]
and from center is lewis for the catch
game
over